Tunisia is a country with deep political
divisions
but there's one thing that still unites
people
brings people together and they
sympathize with each other when a game
is on it's all they think about they
forget about politics and the things
that are happening in the country they
forget about their problems
we all support Tunisia all of us we
forget about the functions supporting
the president and the other supporting
mother in politics Wiki football out of
politics
dissolved Parliament and sect the
government to rule by decree last year
and move the opposition has called a
coup
tunisians have been left frustrated by
years of political argument and economic
stagnation
the World Cup is the only thing that's
left for us in Tunisia it's the way out
and the thing that brings everyone
together regardless of the differences
we see in politics or economic problems
Qatar 2022 will be tunisia's sixth
appearance at a World Cup they've never
made it out of the group stage and have
won just two games at the tournament
fans and Tuners hope the country's large
expat community in Doha will give the
Eagles of Carthage an advantage this
time around
hopefully our Tunisian Community there
will encourage the team especially
during the first matches
hopefully we can get out of the group
stage we've had enough of leaving early
achieving that won't be easy with group
games against defending Champions France
as well as Denmark and Australia
Paul vanderworth Al Jazeera